this little flirt mans between you and
Brooklyn Heights is that what they call
it up man I've been dozing broken banjee
uh with this little cut about a type
stuff girl there's quite a romance yet
might turn into a showmance right now
you guys are just flirty well you heard
of here lives we got a flirt man I've
never heard that word but yeah listen
drag race has the drama the fashion the
runways the one thing we've never had is
a romance right and so when I heard
rumors that this was happening behind
the scenes I was like well please bring
me that I think it's the one thing we
haven't delivered on an epic season of
drag race and it's about time what do
you make of that budding romance I don't
know we really have to watch and wait
you were so good yesterday the spirit
the Holy Ghost it might be some
beautiful blossom from this workroom I
think they're gonna be a really cute
couple if they become a couple I don't
know I'm waiting to see it's like it's
like The Bachelor two things heat up
from there then it'll look for a peeping
tom tease watching miss go get out of
drag y'all I'm sorry y'all missing in
action cuz this good you don't get to
see that you didn't know that what's
happening did you know yeah no we didn't
get to know anything in people leave it
at that we don't know anything I don't
know who knows obviously but the judges
don't know what goes on in the workroom
so when I watch it as you watch it we're
watching it together for the first time
I like that though having [ __ ] trade
I think she's very handsome I mean
listen it first of all everything I you
know I'm very authentic so what you see
is what you get it is what it is and you
know when you chops up and you if
there's somebody you see if you see a
pizza tray coming in and you not gonna
make a move maybe just a little bit of a
little bit of crown you just have to
tune in and see what happens you just
met
okay especially Brooklyn you could pop
up for date but me now hey Chi Chi in a
crown keke cry cry cry at times
[Music]
[Applause]